[Music]
this is the local news roundup with
Conan O'Brien and Andy Richter
tonight's top story
more bad luck for a man on the street
reporter Michael Putnam I'm sorry to
bother you and Michael Putney with you
and also for Janice Golding who let an
escaped convict walk by freely her case
was put over much to the disappointment
of many supporters who have gathered
here and waited most of the day
[Applause]
also this newsman doesn't know how to
make transitions
good evening I'm Ken Bastida dana is off
tonight
he was murdered and then set on fire
while celebrating his birthday
[Applause]
and this one doesn't know how to talk to
women it's time now for a full look at
your forecast with Astrid maybe we can
canoodle before you get into it about
[Music]
what
now let's go to Andy Richter with the
weather Andy not the full weather just a
frustrating tease to keep you tuned in
I'll have my complete forecast in a
moment big news out of Buffalo were the
most annoying kid in the history of the
planet
was located I'm just sitting there on my
iPod it's just so frustrating I want to
be in Florida getting a tan on my back
and yet another another anchor didn't
know the camera was rolling not so pale
honey
today snow is crippling much of the
Washington lowlands
spray-tan one big burning question of
tonight's local news was he wearing
clothes no but naked he was naked and so
was this guy stunned to learn what this
federal complaint oh my goodness and now
once again with your weather
here's Andy rector Andy oh man you will
not believe it I had so much weather
after this and now with sports Andy
Richter after your team was beaten badly
your team's coach had this brilliant
insight they beat us madly and then your
new station ran this terrible local ad
hello this is Cal Cal this is my case
hi what's up Mike my boy just wrecked
the car is your son hurt
not yet Oh Kurt this is Leonard but I
got a business opportunity I'd like to
discuss with you why don't you meet me
an office in about a half hour you've
got friends in the insurance business
next it was time for old ladies
reenactments of fighting off burglars he
was banging over the hip push that
though he stopped that dough and he came
out he was tortured me
[Applause]
wait sorry looks like we ran out of time
for andis weather tonight get and that
was your local news roundup with Conan
O'Brien and Andy Rickey